little piece of business to do first
then we get going sorry the seat's wet
we'll tell you about that
later it's a shitty show you're on right
now well I sort of wanted to normalize
the word wank in America because it's
like not used that much so hi my name is
Ed Sharon and I feel wank about being
on oh about being Conan O'Brien's friend
you uh it's it can get used in lots of
situations yeah I think that could go so
many different ways none of them good I
think there's nothing good about you
feeling wank about being my friend I
will say I was thinking about this you
came on my show uh two times and the
first time you came on the show am I
right that you were Barefoot when you
performed
no I feel like I look like a hobbit but
I don't like I don't practice Hobbit
isms I'm pretty sure you were Barefoot I
took a lot of pills that night I don't
remember what happened no I do do
Barefoot I remember I uh I went Barefoot
for like a summer when I was recording
and I was making a song with Bruno miles
and I remember him just being like just
put some shoes on man Jesus
was it helping you was was writing and
recording Barefoot giving you some kind
of special energy like connecting you to
the earth oh really no just like it was
hot I gave you such an out for doing
something so cool connecting to the
vital powers of the earth and you just
said no it was hot um Ed we have a lot
to talk about because we have some
things in common I know that you are
from England but you uh have a lot of
Irish heritage do you yeah my dad's
Irish yeah and I feel like red the red
head is head ISM um but did you get a
tough time at school for being a red
head well yeah it wasn't just because my
hair was red uh let's just say there
were other problems too my personality
were you that tall in school though no I
got tall later on I um got tall very
late it was like later in high school so
I was very average height I had bright
orange hair my mother insisted on
cutting our hair for us cuz she didn't
want to pay for us to go to a barber
shop so she would cut it straight across
definely uh in a bowl cut my two front
teeth were dead so I had gray teeth up
front um I was I could keep
going but it was a train
rack and uh then the red hair and then
my name is Conan so you put all those
things together and it was a terrible
time what's it like is there anti-red
head bias in England you think at the
time that you were growing up yeah I
think I think it's I think it's just
School cuz actually as soon as I got out
of school like no one cared it wasn't
like I mean my it gets referred to
whenever whenever there's a review of my
album or there's like it's always flame
hair or like red head or like whatever
but I guess that's just a way of
describing someone but yeah it's uh
anything that makes you different I
think later becomes an advantage oh 100%
but when you're a kid I just wanted to
look like everybody else I did not want
to look different when I
not stand out and then I looked like
Pata that had been very assembled and uh
but I think it helps like especially
going into show business like I had a
tiny tiny guitar and I would gig around
London and everyone would know me as the
fat ginger kid with the small guitar so
no no no but it was good cuz I was
remembered people were like oh it's that
it's that it wasn't like oh that tall
good looking bloke with the big guitar
it was always like the fat ginger kid
with the guitar and people knew who I
was did you play a tiny guitar on
purpose or it just it was more like I'd
won a battle of the bands when I was 17
and they gave me a voucher to a music
store and I remember going in the music
store and seeing this small guitar and
being like that would be perfect for
like traveling CU I took chains and
tubes everywhere so I was like that
would be perfect just to have on my
backpack and I'll have all my CDs and
pedals and everything in the bag rather
than like lugging around the big guitar
so it actually was more out of ease and
then it became my thing and now that's
what I use on stage so that's why people
think think you're 65 ft tall it's just
all they using their frame of reference
is completely off I went to go and watch
uh uh Barbie with with uh some friends
and there were these guys in the queue
in front of me and they look around and
they went is that Sharon and one of them
went nah n shar's much taller than
that I have had many people and this is
not a joke just cuz you said that I've
had many people say to me you look like
Conor O'Brien if he were tall right cuz
I'm sort of on a 6' four spect and
people that just knew me for almost 30
years on television think of me as a
very just compact person that can fit in
their television and when this big
monster is looming in front of them you
know one of those balloons that's in
front of a car dealership they uh they
don't know they just think well he can't
be
him